The Konami Code, also known as the Konami
Command and sometimes the Contra Command is
among the most enduring Easter eggs in video
game history.
For those of you who aren’t familiar, there
are a number of video games released by Konami
over the years in which entering up, up, down,
down, left, right, left, right, B, A will
result in the player being granted a host
of power-ups or a bonus of some kind, depending
on the game.
While the code itself was initially featured
in the 1986 Famicom (“Family Computer”,
better known the world over as the Nintendo
Entertainment System) port of Gradius, it
is best known for its appearance in the 1988
NES port of Contra, in which it granted the
player 30 additional lives.
So who invented the Konami Code and why was
it put in the game?
When Gradius was being ported to the NES,
the guy in charge of developing and testing
it, Kazuhisa Hashimoto, wasn’t very good
at the game.
This was a problem because part of his job
included playing all the way through it to
make sure there were no bugs or errors.
To make beating the game easier, Hashimoto
inserted a code that would grant him a full
arsenal of power-ups.
As to the story behind the specific pattern,
Hashimoto stated, “There isn’t one really.
I mean, I was the one using it, so I just
put in something I could remember easily.”
After he finished testing the game, Hashimoto
forgot to remove the code before clearing
it for release and the game went into production
with the code still lingering in the game’s
program.
Hashimoto’s fellow developers at Konami
liked his idea for a code that made games
easier to complete when testing them out,
and similarly began inserting them into other
games they were working on to make their jobs
easier.
Exactly how the Gradius power up code became
known to general gamers isn’t clear.
But when it did, knowledge of it quickly spread
via word of mouth, inspiring Konami developers
to put the same code in the NES port of Contra
to serve as an Easter egg of sorts for gamers
who played Gradius and Gradius 2 (the latter
of which also contained the same cheat code).
Of course, as anyone who’s played Contra
will tell you, completing the game without
the Konami Code is difficult, if not nigh-on
impossible without superhuman reflexes, perhaps
also inspiring the developers to have mercy
on gamers by keeping the code in.
The code would later become synonymous with
Contra thanks to massive coverage from gaming
publications like Nintendo Power, who famously
revealed its existence to thousands of young
gamers in their first ever issue in 1988.
Due to the code’s massive popularity with
gamers, Konami decided to implement it in
virtually all subsequent sequels to both Gradius
and Contra while also inserting it into many
of their other titles, because why not?
Since then, numerous other game makers have
used the same code (appearing in over 200
video games to date), and it has also spread
to other forms of media, including being featured
in songs, TV shows, movies, and on various
websites, such as BuzzFeed.